meet Center Defender Yusuf gang he's
from Senegal suburb of refusk and in
January a man from Gambia presenting
himself as a football agent told him he
had talent and had found a club for him
to join in Dubai Yusuf thought his
dreams had come true and was told he
just needed to pay the man three
thousand five hundred dollars that's a
small fortune for his family so they
sold their car and borrowed money for
the trip but there was no Club to host
him he ended up in prison for months
accused of overstaying his visa and was
then deported back home
I am so disappointed to have spent three
and a half thousand dollars and go to
Dubai only to return empty-handed it's
just so difficult to live with this and
start all over again gay is not alone to
have been duped according to a recent
report from the University of Nottingham
in the UK at least 15 000 young men were
trafficked from West Africa to Europe
and the Middle East in 2021 with a
promise they'd play professional
football most were minors
is a football Academy where the
Senegalese star sajomane was spotted
here they work with professional clubs
abroad
now the two top players will be sent to
the French football club Mets but the
vast majority of the young men that you
see on this pitch will not make a living
playing professional football there will
be disappointment for them to carry of
their families but also of entire
communities and Villages that have
supported them many hope this 22 year
old Central Defender Usman so will be
selected by a professional Club
my family my friends my community
everybody is waiting on me to succeed
success means a contract not only does
the academy make money on a potential
transfer but the player's Community
expects to cash in too his is a possible
future worth betting on one that may
mirror that of a famous Senegalese
player if you look at what big names in
football earn this makes families dream
parents hope their children becoming
Sergio money will help them to build
mosques homes hospitals and even petrol
pumps and stations in their Village
but Yusuf gay is in debt and robbed of
his dreams and yet he has not lost hope
and neither has his family they still
expect their son will step into the
football boots of Senegal's biggest
players and change their lives Nicholas
Hawk Al Jazeera hafusk Senegal